はい 次にまあ良いもの悪いものを判断する能力がもう身についたっていうところから
で 体と心っていうことの勉強に行きます
体とは何？心とは何とはっきり勉強しないといい加減なことを言えないんですよ
だから これ２つをはっきり勉強していこうとする
はい それから １番目 体ですね
人類の研究 知識はほとんど体のことなんですよ
今まで人類は一生懸命いろんなことを研究して知識開発しているでしょうに
全て体のこと 肉体のこと
他のことは全然何もないんです
ゲノムの研究は体の研究の最終段階になるかもしれませんと
まあこれは私はただいい加減に書いて
本当にそうかどうか分かりませんだけど
一応人のゲノムというものはね
どんどん今もう解読して解読して終わっていて
またいくつかのステップはありますけど
まあそれも終わったら
まあ体のことはもう終わったでしょうと思います
将来的に何かこのそれぞれの個人に合わせた薬も作りますよとかね
まあまあ 今いろいろ夢の話は言ってますけどね
進んではいるが まだまだ知識は開発途上なんです
だから ずっともう何百年も何千年も
人間はいろんな知識開発はしているんですけど
最終的にこれが答えっていうことに至ってないんです
まあ知らないものはいっぱいあるんです
さらにさらに研究するっていうことになっているんです
だから 我々の体に対する知識っていうのは
いつでも開発途上ということなんです
皆の興味があっても 仏教ではほとんど興味のない課題です
この体のことは すべての生命の興味がある課題ですけど
仏教には興味がないんです
肉体に対しては ゲノムの研究は終わったんでしょうがとかね
まあ全部 DNA の解読は終わったかとか
どうでもいいということになってます
仏教ではそんなのは ですから
仏教と世間の見方が違うんですね
体に対して 俗世間では体が大事なもので高く評価しています
我々にとっては自分の体っていうのは大事で大事ですごい高く評価していますよ
この肉体を 命の尊厳などの言葉はあるが
結局は肉体のことなんです
命は全然気にしないので
命の尊厳という単語はみんな使って
みんなと言ったっても使ってはいるんだけども
肉体のことを考えているんです
それから体の不思議という単語がありますね
時々テレビ番組もありますね
体の不思議とかね 俗世間では構造と機能の不思議ですよ
NHK でやる体の不思議番組であっても
なんて見事に体が不思議にいろんなことをして
敵を退治して自分を守って見事に頑張っているのかどうかね
その説明なんですね 神経がどう働くのか
脳細胞をどう働くのか
働くのかどうかね 音はどうやってもう理解するのかどうか
そこであの CG もありますね
もう体の中に入って もう細胞のレベルで物事を
なんか映画も一つあったんですね
あの まあふざけた映画もなんか一人の人がね
小さくなって 体の中に注射されちゃって
それで体の中に行って
この人の病気を治してやるぞとかね
で まあ大変なことが とにかくまあその場合でも
この体の中の構造はまあ題材にして映画を作りたかっただけのことなんですけど
で NHK の俳優 何でしたっけ？この特別番組でね
体のことをいろいろ見たっても
不思議不思議だと言うんですよ
体の不思議 それは肉体のことを言ってます
肉体の不思議 だから肉体のことしか知らないんです
仏教には自然法則に逆らって機能することは興味があるんですよ
仏教から見ると この神経の不思議や脳細胞の不思議やらと
そんなのは別にどうったことないんですよ
栄養はいかに分解して
もう血液で持っていって
もう肝臓で処理してとかね
それよりは仏教の不思議なのは
この肉体が自然法則に逆らって生きているんです
これが不思議ですと そこに悔いがあるんですよ
なんで普通の物体と違うんですかと
なんで自然法則に逆らっているんでしょうかと
私はよく言っていることは
なんで人間立っているのかと
これっておかしいんじゃないかと
それは他の科学者も誰も気にしない
当たり前だと思ってる
当たり前じゃないんですよ
人間が立っていられないはずなんです
物質なら 物体なら動けないはずなんです
ちゃんと物理化学を知ってるならば
これがありえないと知ってるはずですよね
だから ニュートンさんがリンゴが落ちることに驚いちゃったんですけど
仏教は人が立っていることに驚くんですね
ということは リンゴが落ちるのは当たり前なら
人間も立っていられないのは当たり前なんです
倒れるはずなんです リンゴが落ちるということは不思議じゃないんです
それは物理法則 しかし
人が立つことが不思議です
ありえないんです 猿が木を登ることは信じられない不思議なんです
これは宇宙の法則では説明できません
猿という物体は物体だからね
もう地面に落ちるのは普通でしょうね
でもみんな逆を言ってるでしょ
猿は木から落ちる これがなんかおかしいと
それがおかしくない それが自然です
猿が木を登ることはおかしいんです
ある物体は勝手に上にあげると
それはありえないで 例えばこのマイクスタンドは勝手に上にあがるってことはないでしょうに
このままでしょうに だからこれ倒れると落ちることは自然でしょ
しかし このマイクスタンドは猿だと思ったらもう登るんだからね
だからそちらに不思議さがあるんですよ
宇宙法則に逆らうところは
宇宙の法則っていうのは
もう太陽を回っているわね
もう惑星はね また太陽が爆発したり
新しいものが現れたりするわとかね
それはすごく計算もできる
予測もできる 一定した法則なんです
しかし 生命の働きだけはなんの計算もできません
猿は木を は木を登っていても
どこまで登るかと思う
予測できません しかし
凧を空に上げると どこまで上げられるかということは計算できますよ
猿が木のてっぺんまで登るか
途中でやめるか 途中で別の枝に変えるか
あるいは途中でまた降りるかわからないんですね
だから 生命の働き 動きっていうのは一つも計算できない
法則作られませんし 科学には完璧に逆らっています
面白いことは 世の中で我々もいろんな嫌味を言われているんだが
あんた方は科学を知らんでしょとかね
我々はすごい科学を発展してるぞとか言いながら
自分たちが科学開発し始めた瞬間からのその法則に命が逆らっていっているのに
それに気づかなかったんです
鉄はこのように探るんだよと説明しているのに
肉体の物質はその働きに合わせて合ってないことには気づかなかったのです
ですから このすごく単純に
我々はただもう手を上げること
立っていることさえも
もう科学世界にはもうではもう説明できない
もうそれの法則に合わない
世界です 仏教はそちらに興味がある
肉体に対してはもっと単純だからね
あまり興味がないんです
体が現れたことが 生まれて
それから体のためにいかなる苦労も惜しまず
残虐 何でしたっけ？行為をしてでも体を守り
何としてでも死を避ける道は世間的な見方です
それで世間の人間ってどういうことかというと
体が現れたことには生まれた
生まれたと言うんです
それから残虐なことをしてでも生き続けたいと思いますね
それから 何としてでも死ぬことだけ避けたいと思っているでしょうに
それが世間の生き方なんですね
よく見ると肉体しか考えてないんです
それは肉体の話であって
病死に襲われる脅威は少ないと錯覚すると
今の時代そうなんですよ
病気にはならないでしょう
もう結構薬も開発しているんだからとかね
まあいろいろ時効に合わない限りはね
昔と違って もう次から次に人が死ぬことは今ないんですよね
それも安全な国だけ 中東とかね
アフリカとか そこら辺は違いますよ
もういつでも人が死んじゃいますからね
安全な国だったらまあそんなに死ぬこともないんですね
だから病と死は 死のに襲われる脅威っていうのはね
ないんだ 少ないんだと錯覚するんです
本当はありますけどね
そうするとみんな何考えるのかというと
スマートに スマートで美しく
活発的で 長生きをして体を楽しませる
楽しませることに興味が変わるんです
それは皆様がやっていることなんです
明日病気で死ぬという恐れがないでしょう
だからスマートになりたいとかね
できるだけ美しくて活発的でとかね
そんなものを考えているんです
ちゃんと体重を減らしてとか
あれって結局肉体のことを考えてるだけなんです
これが世間の見方です
だから世間が知っているのは肉体のことだけ
しかし 肉体が科学に逆らって反して機能していることには気づかないんです
それで仏教の見方は 人間の生き方を観察する
仏教はもうまず生き方って何だと全部観察するんですね
普遍的な答えを見出すんです
生きるっていうのは何だと
何か答えがあるのかと
これを探すんですよ 体には生命が極端に執着している
これを発見するものなんですよ
これを覚えていた方がいいんです
生命というのは この肉体にものすごく極端に執着している
言わなくたってわかるでしょ
みんな肉体のことしか知らないんだからね
何を食べればいいかとかね
どんな運動した方が体重が減らすのかとかね
それしか興味がないでしょう
だから肉体のために肉体を宗教にして
肉体の奴隷で生きてるんです
だから肉体に どんな生命でも肉体には極端に執着しているんだぞということを
仏教はとても簡単に発見するんです
この執着の衝動が生きる力になっている
だから生きる力っていうのはすごいわかりやすい
生きる力っていうのは
この肉体にくさりかけてる肉体にある執着なんです
あまりにも肉体に執着しているんだから
もうあまりにも現金で生きているんです
体のためなら何でもやるぞと
期待する刺激が体に入ると喜びと欲を感じ
それで肉体が期待する刺激がもらうと
ああ 楽しいとか喜びを感じて欲を感じる
期待外れの刺激に対して不幸と怒りを感じるんです
これも仏教が発見するものなんです
生命を見て あんたはなんか刺激があるでしょ
今楽しい期待した刺激が
だから楽しいでしょうねとかね
だから欲があるでしょうねとかね
そこで今あなたの刺激は期待外れでしょう
だから今怒っているでしょう
不幸だと思っているでしょうと
そういうことなんです
それで すべての生命はそんなものになっています
肉体主義で肉体に刺激を与えることで生きている
刺激が期待したものだったら楽しい
期待しなかったものだったら楽しくない
不幸 というふうに仏教の見方なんです
変わることは普遍的な法則なので
努力をしても老病死を乗り越えないということは仏教が発見する真理なんです
そこで物事は変わるんですよ
地球ももう自転しながら回ってるんだからね
止まらないんです 太陽もずっと燃えっぱなしだから
もう変化しているんです
地球も太陽も燃えると同時に変わっているんです
何者も止まらないんです
だから人間に笑っちゃうんです
仏教はね あんたがた いくら踏ん張ってもね
変わることは止まらない
止まりませんよ だから
生きているものは病気にならないように
長生きできますように
もう決して死なないように頑張ってますけどね
ありません そんなことは
邪魔を入れるんだと だから
老いること 病になることと死ぬことっていうのは確実に来るんだ
生命にはと それも仏教が発見する生命の見方なんですね
生きることは本来苦だからこそ
生命は常に楽幸福を探し求めている
もう一つ 仏教は発見することがあるんですよ
何でもこんなに必死でみんな楽しみを探してますかね
子供にしたって もうゲームやりたいし
遊びたいし もう必死なんですね
大人も遊びたい 遊びたいと必死なんですね
嫌な仕事を辞めたいんですよ
楽しい仕事をしたいんですよ
なんでそんなに夢中夢中夢中になってますかと
そんなにもむきになって
なんで楽しみ探してるんですかというと
結局あんた楽しくないでしょってことなんです
今楽しいんだったら むきになって探す必要ないでしょ
今お腹が満腹だったら
必死でレストランを探しながら走る必要ないでしょ
お腹が空いちゃって もう上に上の状態になってるんだったら
もう必死でもうもう食べ物ないかと探すんですからね
だから何か探すということが
それがないということなんです
ということで 人間は楽しみを探しているということは
人間には楽しみがないということなんです
あるんだったら探しません
それで答えは 生きることは苦ですと
生きることは苦だからこそ楽しみを探しているんです
それで仏教 ブッダの話では
生きることは苦であると
もう結論だけ出しています
それはすべてよく観察した上で出している普遍的な答えなんです
一般人にはそれを見つけることはできないんです
これ 逆を言えばわかりますからね
生きることは幸福でたまらないと言えるなら
こんなに苦労しないんだからね
人生には だから生きることって
もう楽しくて幸福でたまらんと言うんだったら
何もやる必要ないんです
でも 人間っていうのは結構大変苦労して生きてますよ
肉体の現れ これショーですね
で 苦しみ 維持することで苦しみ
老いることで苦しみ 病で苦しみ
絶対的に避けたい死を迎えて苦しむんです
全部苦しいんです 肉体が現れることも苦しいし
肉体維持することもまた苦しいしね
まあそういう風にこの苦しみの流れが生まれるんだろう
したがって 肉体修行主義の生き方は正しくない
仏教の結論なんです この肉体修行主義ではね
これは苦しみ修行主義のような話でね
変えてくださいと 意味がないんだ